house come raise monies Peter Pat and
welcome to three free games and puts or
whatever call it whatever the [ __ ] you
want I don't care
first game up today it's call of a
beaver call mommy no god damn that is
badass oh my god so MIT is all right
controls yeah that looks great
oh my god the capes the Cubs want to
deport me back to Canada I'll never go
back to that forsaken land died died a
couple Eber [ __ ] what a great cover is
this it watch out wait is this game over
I thought I won isn't this the point I
thought people who had to die I don't
get it
weapon upgrades all right let's buy that
sheet Center sheet okay so apparently
there's a cheat
call of Bieber gay whorfin so I got the
wallpaper that's great
what's the other world paper haircut
plus [ __ ] equals Bieber that's a
fantastic wallpaper who wouldn't want to
have that a lot of people hate Bieber so
much they make a game that is this
admirer Bowl hate right there this is
clearly the best game ever oh god what
the [ __ ] that poster is serious oh man I
sure what I don't remember doing that -
I sure what the hell man that's so weird
I swear I'm not gay stupid cops think
they can stop me I'll send my fangirl
army on you yeah this is the best game
ever
I have ever played ever that's the best
game ever
all right well [ __ ] this next game is
whack your beer frame game is old but
it's supposed to be funny and Ken played
it and I was like alright I'll play it
then will the weapon be used for your
ex-boyfriend or the ex-boyfriend oh wow
there's gonna be a lot of tumblr post
about this one this looks like good I
don't know what that is this is a wart
what what that's not supposed to
she became a lesbian yep and I'm okay
with it friendly yeah what you can't
just have a man's hours our eyes out
well you're her lesbian that's is not
okay I think maybe don't don't hate me
what is this what it's gonna crash on
who I think him oh that's so cured oh
how is that all right this game is
violence against women this is not okay
except I guess it's okay so cuz it's men
to this don't write a tumblr post please
you never know who's gonna die
[Music]
that wasn't too bad she's fine
oh maybe not and I got a new best friend
what is this
oh-oh-oh I need that gun I need it now
what is this what the [ __ ] am I secretly
a penis to see this is what this game is
about I'm [ __ ] myself
wonderful wonderful laptop that can't be
harmful the rides here he gives you on
the Oh can't you guys just get along
here have a car gold digger what why do
they have to shoot me
dad what this game is so dark it's so
dark and how could he think when he gets
shot what is this oh he discovered
minecraft Scotty okay then alright then
yeah I have a gift just for you women
and gifts a jetpack is that a jetpack no
it's a my dead
what was the point of giving a gift just
gonna do that oh my god new shoes
girls like new shoes I think Jesus
Christ okay that was that was just weird
all right credit card I'll buy her hey I
want those things come on did you have
to do that I don't understand just came
at all what is this it's raining that's
not too bad a shark from the skies why
the [ __ ] not why the [ __ ] and not
chocolate chocolate chocolate chocolate
oh oh it's a pie
oh it's a die pie what else do we have
here
airplane brofist wow wow that's it oh my
god I did not need to see
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's two girls in one cup except one
girl in a lot of shape oh my god so what
is he gonna do now he's a gentleman
right now how long were they like super
happy and then just like oh she gets all
the shows in the world what a dead man
he's a great boyfriend hey boo
that's the worst thing you can do fired
all her shoes that's it it's the only
one we should they don't die just
getting rid of all your shoes is worse
than dying apparently I think that was
all of them oh okay so the line is a
secret
Oh God all right I'm pretty sure that
was all of them all right third game I
like how this video turned out to record
in three different days never done that
before third game is all right I don't
have a name for this game it doesn't
tell me oh wait
breakfast simulator there you go the
point of this is to play flappy bird
while you are eating cereals by tapping
and swiping it no [ __ ] way
I can't even play flappy bird [ __ ]
I'm playing flappy see I can't even say
flappy bird who thought this was a good
idea
[ __ ] having breakfast yum nom nom nom
nom nom nom oh my god I got this no I
don't got yeah man [ __ ] you carry on so
I have to swipe and then I have to tap
at the same time this game is just
ridiculous don't play flappy bird when
you eat cereal I've learned this from
this game how the [ __ ] am i eating
cereal
it's so hard this is harder than [ __ ]
the flappy bird oh my god I'm so good
yeah get this ridiculous oh I got a
bronze to spoon now cuz I'm so awesome
alright I got this oh my god you start
getting a momentum on this [ __ ] keep
beating man keep getting faster oh my
god ah how is this a proper breakfast
simulator what are you talking about
you lied to me god this is pissing me
off
I like I can't talk flap a bird and eat
cereal at the same time that's just not
cool man
but I got it cuz I'm a ballast I eat
sauce in my cereals I have sauce in
there it's really good you should try it
that's a great spoonful I got there [ __ ]
you flappy god dammit
I don't want to play anymore alright
that was three three games and parents I
hope you bros enjoyed oh I don't even
like it makes me do this I really do it
already
it's not gonna stop hey shag
yeah that was pretty dumb